What if we found a way to drain all the
earth's oceans through some mysterious
portal at the bottom
of the Mariana trench?
How long would it take
years, centuries, millennia?
Would there be any life left on
earth when the pumping was over?
What if it happened overnight?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
we drained all the world's oceans.
Ocean water makes up 70% of the earth's
surface. How much liquid is that?
Exactly? Well, if you could put all that
water into Olympic size swimming pools,
you'd need this many of them.
Even if we opened a portal about
the size of a basketball court,
it would take us hundreds of thousands
of years to drain the oceans.
They hold over a billion
cubic kilometers of water.
But what if we had a pump powerful enough
to drain all the oceans in a minute?
What would happen then? Sure
enough, swimmers, sailors,
cruise passengers,
everyone out on the ocean would feel
the effects quickly within a second.
Boaters and swimmers in shallow
water would crash onto the bottom.
They'd get away with a few broken bones.
Deep Ocean ships wouldn't be so lucky.
A titanic sized liner would hit the
bottom in 30 seconds and smash into tiny
pieces.
The same thing would happen to just about
every large ship on the ocean within
the first minute. What about all the sea
creatures? You already know the answer.
It would literally be raining fish.
Since all the whales, dolphins,
and other big aquatic animals,
curiously exploring the surface
would be falling to the ocean floor.
As for those already near the bottom,
they'd be lucky not to get sucked
down the drain along with the water.
But what comes next is where
the real trouble begins.
Our oceans have to life supporting roles.
First,
they regulate global temperatures
by absorbing energy from the sun.
They push warm tropical waters north and
south and circulate Coldwater's back to
the equator. This way, no place on
earth gets too hot or way too cold.
Global climate control.
Second Oceans feed the water
cycle evaporating into the
clouds and reigning back
to Earth.
The moment the oceans disappeared,
the earth would turn into a vast desert.
Go ahead and throw away your
umbrella since it's never
going to rain again. Wait,
what about all the lakes and rivers?
Can we get by with those? Well,
without oceans,
the world loses 97% of its water.
The small amount of liquid left would
not be enough to sustain the water cycle.
The pools of drinkable
water would evaporate pretty
fast. In a matter of days,
people and most animals with die from
dehydration plants would have a few weeks
before they started decaying in
the dry air. Within a few months,
forests would begin massive die offs
and all this dry dead vegetation would
eventually ignite.
In a of years,
most of the world's forests
would be burned out.
As these huge bonfires
sparked all across the planet,
the atmosphere would become less and less
oxygenated if there were still humans
at this time,
the unbreathable air and scorching
temperature would wipe us out for good.
All in all the earth would
end up just like Venus cooked,
so why don't I take a few days off and
enjoy a little seaside vacation while you
can?
Isn't it time to explore how your,
what if scenario would turn out.